the Joe Rogan experience that kind of
stress plays a big factor with people's
immune systems all the time when people
are stressed out they always get sick
it's real real common it just makes
sense and I think this kind of fear
particularly I mean the way I was
experiencing it when the when the
lockdown was first ordered and everyone
was at the supermarket no one was
wearing masks yet but everyone was
stockpiling food and you know we were
nervous we were real nervous because we
didn't know what this was gonna be like
and we were also I was nervous
particularly because I feel like the
information we were getting out at China
was not correct and I was worried that
when you see those videos of them
spraying disinfectant on houses and
buildings it's like maybe this is way
worse than we think it is and it's gonna
hit America really hard because we've
been lied to by the Chinese there was a
lot of fear so I remember lying in bed
at night and like testing my breath like
maybe I have it now he's gonna get worse
you know there's a lot of that yeah
there's a lot of that I didn't sleep
real good at all or maybe the first few
days of lockdown until I sort of calmed
down and realized well I'm not going
anywhere I can't get it you know and
then I got tested I'm like okay well
this is nice to know that I don't have
it currently like maybe if I just keep
doing what I'm doing I won't get it but
then you know I'd have days where half
the day I'd think this is all [ __ ]
but we need to do is tell people how to
strength their immune system and then
you read some crazy story about some new
inflammatory syndrome they're finding on
you know some patients where you know
they're their feet are swelling up yeah
blue toes yeah all this yeah they get
scared again
yeah I'm totally with you and I think
that that brings up the issue of how our
society now views death I read an
interesting article just in the last
couple of days about how how as we have
left it used to be when we were kids we
used the term somebody drop dead
remember that you know they they just
drop dead little days all right
well today we don't say they drop dead
we say apparently medicine failed them
or the hospital it's like it's like
instead of just people yeah we do drop
dead
instead every death is some sort of a
failure of our techno sophisticated
cryogenic you know system that's
supposed to keep everybody you know
beautiful and perfect forever perfect
forever and and the fact the fact is you
know on and I think that's an advantage
of on the farm where we are I mean we we
see death every day I mean we we know
that things and and in fact in fact
death makes room I mean a compost pile
is its death in life I mean it's it's
it's you've got microbes eating stuff
that was living and then and then that
makes new life and of course my family
knows that that when I go they're
supposed to put me in a compost pile you
know dude really yeah yeah put me in a
compost pile I mean uh is that legal
though don't they have to cremate you I
think I think that at least put me in
the ground or something but that's my
joke yeah I think they're allowed to
just put you in the ground I think they
have to pump you up with chemicals no no
no no no my dad my dad nothing read
anything nope in the ground that was it
did you have to sign paperwork saying
that he didn't kill you dad or anything
pictures you know what no no what we did
have to get was a special use permit for
a family graveyard so we've got we've
got ten we've got permission for ten
spots so you don't have to use
formaldehyde no no but nothing no
everywhere else you do though correct
you either
cremate or well from now on I think
these formaldehyde before they cremate
well there's there are now burgeoning
around the country there are natural
cemeteries really yeah and and they're
there especially permitted cemeteries
where there's you know nothing nothing
is is used but we're promised as they
can't exhume anybody right exhume your
bones I guess yeah about the bones would
stay for a good while we know the bones
last a long time but you know my my
thing is that look I don't want I don't
want a bunch of people to die but but
the fact is that that death is is
transformative and I don't get all too
mystical and
but whatever your your spiritual
tradition is I mean mine happens to be
judeo-christian ethic so I think there
is an afterlife but but but even even if
even if there's nothing even if you say
well I'm dead and there's no spirit and
I'm gone
even so that makes room for tomorrow's
babies it makes room for new ideas new
things I mean you you can't you can't
have you can't have life without the
regenerative regenerative capacity of
death and and and the the foundation of
ecology is life death decomposition
regeneration life death no regeneration
might be look like something else okay
but but that's that's that's our
digestion
it's compost it's you know it's
everything and when and when we get
sterilized and and and move away from
that I think we lose the beauty of the
transformative capacity of that part of
life yeah I think it speaks to what you
were talking about earlier that they
look at death as some sort of a failure
instead of just a part of the natural
cycle
[Applause]